we understand that retail banks depend
on temenos apps to process essential
banking transactions
from deposits and withdrawals to
critical loans
in this demo our fictional bank has
deployed their transact
core banking app running on new odb
distributed database
on anthos google kubernetes engine or
gke
giving them the flexibility to run
production workloads on premises in
their own data center
while also having a secondary site on
google cloud
set up for bursting to handle unforeseen
surges and core banking transactions
fell over to the cloud for disaster
recovery and auto scaling back down to
maintain business as usual
this full demo of donelive spans one
hour so keep in mind that we have edited
for time
let's take a quick tour of the dashboard
starting on the upper left you can see
the activemq message queue count
going down the left side you see the
transact and nuodb
cpu and nuodb commits on param and in
the cloud
we're using j meter to load the
transactions into activemq
so on the upper right chart we present
the number of transactions per second
in this demo the system on prem is built
to handle a maximum normal load of 20
transactions per second
going down the right side see the two
gke nodes ready to go
with the ability to auto scale up to
five nodes transact on premise has to
scale up to 3 replicas
after that to support additional load
transact is set to scale up to 19
replicas in google cloud gke
and on the bottom we show how new db
transaction engine
is also set to scale up to three
replicas
as we've been going through the tour you
can see that with the exception of a
brief spike
the system has been processing a fairly
steady and quote-unquote normal load of
about 13 transactions per second
in the active mq chart you can also see
that for the most part
transactions are being processed right
away so messages are not queuing up
all looks good so far we've started fast
forwarding so you can see how google
cloud can help with the sudden surge
up to 150 transactions per second and
beyond
gke transact replicas scale to 19 and
gke nodes auto scale up to 5.
new odb transaction engine will also
scale up to 2 with the cpu utilization
rate exceeding the target
messages are building in the queue we
fast forward more to show how the system
is coping well with the increasingly
heavy load
and that activity in the new odb
transaction engine replicas is
converging
finally we reach peak activity of about
250 transactions per second
messages really start accumulating as
this is too much for the system to
handle
now we simulate a worst case scenario in
this demo
failure on premises at the maximum load
in this dr scenario cloud is just about
managing the messages while the on-prem
site is down
after about 470 seconds of downtime
the on-prem data center is operational
again
next we'll show how transact on google
cloud is set to automatically scale back
down
when transaction loads return to normal
messages have gone down to zero
transaction engine activity converges
and transact replicas in google cloud
scale back to one
and new odb transaction engine in the
cloud also scales down to two
the system in the cloud continues to
scale down
new odb transaction engine replicas are
now down to a minimum
and the gke nodes are starting to scale
back down from 5
to 2 as well
in conclusion this demo showed how
transact
can be set up to burst seamlessly from
on-premises to google cloud
to handle unforeseen spikes in load how
it can fail over to the cloud
and also auto scale back down again to
maintain business
as usual thank you for watching
you